yeah let's do this man really yep
sometimes you procrastinate before you
start a podcast we just been sitting
here eating food Oh doughnuts
Chinn bought us twelve left two minutes
car overnight that's all right it's in
the old they lost all their moisture so
what I'll tell you they're all stuck
together they're all stuck together baby
still night the icing is delicious my
pancreas is shooting out a lot of
insulin right [ __ ] how was your how was
your voodoo doughnut experience where'd
you go Studio City it's in Universal
CityWalk
if you go to Universal Studios you know
side thing over next to it yeah the city
walk area so that's our way it was
Abby's to get know the only thing is the
parking cost $25.00 there's just no way
around it unless you're sneaky and you
gotta have my dog yeah got how many
doughnuts 12 what it cost you total
won't oh so I got you guys I got my
roommates and then the parking was about
a hard under 700 total but the doughnuts
should have cost around 14 15 bucks for
the Dozen no more and more no all three
bucks each no no no I was just there
they're a dollar something is that true
yeah you know what it came out to like
$45 45 bucks and then 25 for the parking
so maybe you're inflating a little bit
just so you know let's get a little bit
more white Voodoo's butter and blue star
cos blue star is 475 there you go that's
crazy
and for these donuts like go bright
under two bucks yeah they're dollar
stuff and they're delicious yeah was
there a lion chin or no the line wasn't
that bad like what time did you go did
you go at 3:00 in the morning after you
killed people
it was after after we recorded yet
yesterday damn you drove during traffic
yeah I had to stop by that place I'm
leasing so I just stopped by there first
then went to the doughnut shop and then
went back here did you sign the lease
yeah everything set going down okay it's
going down baby yeah walk with your
pants down yeah there you go there you
go there you go wait oh so he said you
know what it is dude I'm straight there
you go
yeah but look at my psoriasis guess what
when's the dermo yesterday oh he did
she goes there is something you can do
about I go there is she goes 100% I'll
give you this like vitamin D cream with
this cortisone it'll take it right down
go away I was like really how about this
bottom I know she goes yeah get rid of
that for forever be the spot a new nose
got a little freckle on my nose I don't
like having it nothing wrong with a
freckle
well Freck so I'm cream did it help she
says will work in by six weeks
everything will be gone six yeah every
day thanks for enough I know their press
release gonna go away yeah the problem
with like applying a cream it's like too
much work I know like the woman who's
does art was standing on the Goldbergs
she said she was wearing sneakers she
goes Asics III have to wear a six echo
watch because I have the craziest high
arches I go oh man you must been a fast
runner or something i say she goes well
i am obsessed with my feet i I wash them
every night I massage them and I put
cream on that I go you put cream on your
feet every night she goes okay I have to
if my feet are a little dry and they
touch the sheets I can't stand it oh oh
she has an issue with it I was like you
are a foot fetish man's and Shrieve she
attractive she's attractive oh wow and
she's know all about her feet yep she's
got these little some people are into
feet some people are like you know
there's a whole team or no division
that's just dudes getting jacked off of
people I think I sure do they put their
dick between your feet and then you rub
your feet of it that doesn't seem
enjoyable or they or they they make a
douche on your feet do this just for a
minute straight that never did a thing
for me oh my my thighs a burn yeah and
I'm gonna say this out loud I love my
daughter so much and she's beautiful she
could water-ski our feet she's beaming
as a kid I went those I look to the
nurse I go excuse me are those feet
supposed to be that big they would nurse
cuz they are a little long I was like a
little long
well my dad's got size 14 and her
grandfather has gotten size 14 does your
son have big feet nope
just your daughter little arched
adorable feet when I was at that Nike
headquarters in Portland there's a size
and at geez I wonder why I didn't sell
theirs they had these New Jordans
there's only one pair left I like it
jangle oh [ __ ] they got my legs a size
18
Wow who the [ __ ] you know [ __ ] there's a
size 18 money they were like this big
all we have is an 18 no all that's left
is an 18 Oh
classroom that's a bomber to have
feedback big gee whiz it's MEA let me
have yeah I'm happy yeah all of them are
just Giants being that that bakes just
not fun man I don't think so unless your
name be yeah unless you're super
proportion like I wouldn't mind I was in
I was on a plane on the way to Minnesota
and there was this cold this very
handsome dude with long hair and he was
standing at the bathroom and and and he
just looked like he probably was a wide
he looked like a white guy wide receiver
in the NFL like but even bigger like a
tight end but but thin but long I get
that same in the word maybe he looked
like a like a really good volleyball
player but muscular and no sound it
sounds that you know it is what the [ __ ]
taser you just hanging out by the
bathroom no no he was just waiting to go
to the bathroom but he had this long
hair and he had these long hands and I
was just like that's such an easy bone
structure it'd be so easy to be that
tall 6 7 and just jewelry's you out and
wrap people up for nobody I come off
with your feet high I just I know I
can't stop staring at people like that
cuz I take him in and he looked so weird
it's so uncomfortable for that it was
some portion new kid I can't he had I
had muscular everything was in
proportion he looked like a guy who
could just dog like a Greek said yeah he
looked like he could dunk and then swim
really fast and and like and run through
African tall grass you know if he could
do it all like he could run down a deer
you're obsessed with him yeah I'm gonna
run that deer down and then when he
asked me what he did was like dude I
work at AMC Theaters I wanted to ask him
what he did I can't believe you didn't
ask him usually you ask him I throw in
their part and there's a large black
bike ball player well yeah no please
don't do that
yo my man play some ball got pit bulls
well no man I'm just my man that's what
you do as soon as if whenever in
there.put if there's a large black man
Brian yo my man what team the guys are
what what team what team y'all ball
forward yo man let me get a pit bull off
your mom [ __ ] yo [ __ ] yd why do
you do that
could I speak black what team mumble I
speak I speak jive you try to relate to
them too
yo yo man you play ball use me for no
reason
ah yeah that's exactly that ah your mom
phone when I [ __ ] wings out around
here am i right
I'm all you will this is super race
guess I guess the racist yeah it's a
little awkward
yo man be a lot better if we had
basketball in here [ __ ] dude I
[ __ ] know man yeah blood from new JS
I was I was jamming too straight out of
Compton at 6:00 a.m. as I pulled into
traffic
in my [ __ ] with my college degree am
I [ __ ] white Tesla again you hope
dancing this shitty way yeah um I don't
know what it is I think I've just always
wanted to be tall but also I don't want
to be tall and thin gonna be tall and
not a dick just just trolling yeah yeah
yeah you know what I want to be home
tensile I know what I want to look like
Randy Moss he's so thin he's not that
versed in that he's so thin you're seen
his ankles bring him up without a shirt
you know what that's a terrible example
he's so thin he looks like your skeleton
in science class painted black I think
he's actually way more muscular pleasing
not I've seen I've actually worked with
on ESP have you yes so tell me about so
thin really it's not who you want to be
but super strong will be more like
Terrell Owens that way I've seen her own
person but but but Randy's very thin
like alarm alarm no he's like
everybody's thin to you but maybe look
at him look at him very thin no no not
muscat not a muscular man uh thicker
than Jon Jones
no no thinner that way --then Wow yes is
it possible that now that he's not trait
well no I take that that's Dez Bryant
I'll take this Bryan spottings fishing
yeah got skinny like speed dude yeah
he's Cortese of like a basketball player
to me you play basketball
ah six six hats Ozzy no six-four
six-five okay um did you see John Jones
passed the lie detector test I sure did
I sure is it me matters though
I think it has to really yeah the lady
no your flippin scrip not wrong you can
go back and listen to it because we did
a lie-detector test even talking the
lie-detector lady she was like you know
there's some you know margin for errors
yeah but I talked to a guy who a lawyer
said if they do it right with really
good stuff apparently it's it's I was
just Wiggly and I said yeah I said I was
lying about everything even the stuff I
was telling the truth about but date but
if you go up to go type in how accurate
lie detector test because there's a
there's a thing where they say like
sociopaths can't pass yes that's true
that's true that's true because in they
won't they won't raise their heartbeat
or it won't raise their blood pressure
when they lie because they're serial
killer yeah and I'm not saying that's
part with John but I don't think we
should look too much into it yeah and
also I want to know points in a random
test because it was an Albuquerque where
it's a Greek god out there like it had
been to me it'd be carried more weight
if they went hey John passed a
lie-detector test in Florida and we've
randomly flew him down then he had to
take glide take tests and they're
passing like for him to do it on his own
I did what matters is the fact that the
goal percentage basically said he you
know he probably didn't do it knowingly
and I think in that sense that's got to
carry some weight
I agree that's the biggest thing I I
don't think it's a bad look for John
either I think it's a good PR move
because most people see it go oh wow
yeah I think was a smart answer
yeah I hope he comes back I do too I
want him back dude how about it just
flip the scripts here
I was watching uh I was just show called
I am jazz on TLC do you know what it is
she got her start on YouTube she's a
transgender when she was three she's
born a boy when she was three she kept
on her mom like I don't you know I want
to play with the girls I'm a girl just
not his girl mom's like what the [ __ ]
and so she went through hormones she's
going she wants to get the bottom
surgery they called the bomb surgery but
she doesn't have enough skin down there
it's a nightmare but they had a heard
debate this doctor because his doctor
was saying that transgender kids
shouldn't have any hormones any service
to after puberty
you can't agree with that you gotta
watch this because you can't agree with
it you shouldn't you should I thought
the same thing too because the suicide
rate is so high amongst them when
they're when they don't or when they're
not allowed to have estrogen blockers or
hormones because I think if you always
felt some way your closet you feel this
way and the stock does go no no they're
saying so it's like torture for them for
them to have to go through puberty it's
a very very but the promise of two
things one is apparently they switch
their mind no no what is it older one is
one is that first of all I think you're
like for example I think you're born gay
I don't think you I don't think you
decide you're gay right
no they're buying like I would imagine
being transgender is the same thing okay
I feels that way yeah my worry is that
there are people plenty of people who
talked about wanting to have become a
woman or a man and then when they got
older they were like I'm glad I didn't
do it that's not true
no no see so that's why I worry about
really really a life oh I agree right
but not only that I agree with that but
that's what so that's what people's
argument they go well I was on the road
they're gonna switch and the odds are
crazy how many like after kids that know
me well know 60% commit suicide it's
high as [ __ ] but the thing is that how
many kids have the surgery then then go
oh no actually I want to go back the OP
that if they're actual transgender kids
which would they go through all these
clinical studies all that the return
rate is I mean like well here's the
tough part though the tough that the
tougher part also is that even after
operation the suicide rate apparently
doesn't change
so let's look that up because they went
all over this on the show and trans are
a lot of misconceptions right yeah so
the IRA the suicide rate among
transgender when they get the operation
stays the same it yeah I think it goes
down up by much but the reason why third
I'm not saying suicide rates so high is
because of the way society views them
and looks at them yeah that's you
because they can't find their place is
it or is it the fact that they never
really feel like they're women or men
and that's that's the overwhelming thing
- right then
I don't know how like okay so people
accept you you still don't like the way
you are yeah because you have the wiring
of a woman in a man's body
FX pause the long-term studying up to 30
years followed 324 people who had sex
reassignment surgery the study revealed
the beginning about 10 years after
having surgery the transgender began to
experience increasing mental
difficulties most shockingly their
suicide mortality rose almost 20 fold
above the comparable non transgender
population this deserving result as as
yet no explanation but probably reflects
the growing sense of isolation reported
by the aging transgender after surgery
the high suicide rate certainly
challenges the surgery prescription yeah
so I had read this as well and I feel
like surgeries up doesn't want them to
get surgery because they should be
allowed to get surgery of course but I
unfortunately the sad part is I don't
think that is what stops a lot of them
from committing suicide
because it no I don't think it's the
whole thing yeah they still don't feel
the way they want to they still are they
still feel like men you know in a
woman's body or vice versa oh the shame
it's a [ __ ] bummer they had another
parent on there where it was this
african-american mom she said my son
feels like a woman and he's nine and
she's like it's just a tough tough thing
to tackle of course it is man I mean how
do you if that's what's going on in
someone's brain I think the biggest
thing I would you know not young would
it be awful but if my son felt like that
I would feel more bad for him because
it's like Oh miss aside he just doesn't
mean to you can we can do all this stuff
and people say oh equal rights all that
stuff but they just don't live a normal
life even if society accepted it
remember it's like oh like this if
you're really ugly I mean and if this
happens and you never get a date don't
you you that is traumatic as [ __ ] for
people yeah and no matter how accepted
you are you never feel that intimacy you
know for a man to never feel a woman be
overwhelmed with her lust or desire for
you for who you are
boom is here oh yeah and and and you
it's terrible and I think that the same
thing unfortunately for anybody who
feels think about that I'm a man and I
feel like a woman well I'm a man of the
wiring of a woman I have the brain of a
woman but I have the outsides of a man
like cool it's a cruel things are tough
go it's it's gender dysmorphia right and
it's a form of tough it was always
considered a form of mental illness well
you know I know that's not contrib
that's controversial and stuff and it
doesn't matter what you label it or what
you call it the fact of the matter is
man do you have any transgender friends
same j0d no any you have one it's rare
it's always been pretty rare man is he
is he or she how does it work
they manned a woman Wes Iowa West
Hollywood's like her only home so she's
like a dancer a bartender but she's
super smart because people don't take
her seriously for her jobs so she wasn't
been able to get into the corporate
office yet and she's like 36 but she's
way more qualified than anyone I know
so it's crazy my took my girls shooting
this soap opera and there's a
transgender in the show and she's a
beautiful girl like we'd definitely be
fooled mmm in a good way
anyways but a beautiful girl anyways so
just get that Jenna on the show and
gorgeous girl I mean tons of Instagram
followers stuff like that and they shot
a scene where she's in the soap opera is
bullied and they push her down to the
ground so the shooting the scene that
she's wearing heels and you know she
falls and breaks the heel and then the
next day she comes on set hopefully I'm
allowed to say that hope she comes on
set and everyone's like where's your
shoes and she's like oh those were my
only she's so poor she's like those are
my only shoes I don't have any other
shoes I know that makes me [ __ ] sigh
call Joe I went you go buy 10 pairs of
shoes and give her those she was really
I go give her a task go buy a pair and
give her a lot of cash for me
she was really go please do that isn't
ain't bad ain't that the truth when you
see somebody trying to be pretty
but the Gorton gorgeous woman though I'm
straight-up like Gordon no take you make
funny what like door you'd like damn
like she's show me what the [ __ ] she's
saying out she's home like she's been
homeless like she's trying to make you
an act and trying to all the stuff she
can't get a job because transgender like
she's trying all this stuff when you
hear the story like [ __ ] man
there was this I gave her my size 14
they say they day I never forgot the
story about this guy who was a writer
and he was in Russia and he'd been
arrested they just arrested randomly a
lot of people and they would put you on
a in this case they put them on a boat
and they were gonna send them somewhere
to a labor camp or something and when
the men were arrested that they had had
women that were had been arrested and
the women were all down in this hold and
you would be arrested back then for
being you know affiliated married to
somebody who belonged to the wrong party
married or whatever it was there were
all kinds of reasons and these women had
been down there for a while and they
were all forced to go to the bathroom in
a giant steel pot they were kind of
perched over and indignant and because
they'd been down there for a long time
they were dirty and they had some some
of them had things on their skin and so
and when they men he said when we walked
down there and these women were these
were they were just wretches they'd been
in the hall about and they were going in
the bathroom and one of them stopped
immediately going the bathroom this
other man and she they look so terrible
but they started to fix their hair
because the men were there and they they
they were trying to sell some [ __ ]
dignity normal some dignity some
normalcy and and just hold it together
for these men that came down there I
never forgot that story I was like and
that there's something so moving about
that like somebody's trying to be they
can't even afford shoes because they
can't get a real job and then they break
their [ __ ] heel that humiliation
and oh by the way you've dealt at your
whole life I know I can't say I can't
stand that [ __ ] it makes me want to cry
it's a real bummer
yeah do a minor subject you ever yeah I
sure we had we buy her ten parent that's
exactly what she did you go by her to
see the [ __ ] shoes what she did I
said he'd take my card he buy that girl
all the shoes you get it I got one story
for you go ahead so I am me and my buddy
are hanging out we had our shirts off
I'm a young man in
cool [ __ ] Venice cottage on Anoeta
place below oh yeah
and well I mean you know me I'm like
what am i 32 33 I'm cute and my buddy's
a Stifel of coming yeah yeah brittles
was in and out it's [ __ ] Grand
Central I'm putting up numbers blah blah
blah I'm awesome and you know you're
awesome I got my dogs but I had my
parrots back then I'm [ __ ] a loser
yeah yeah a loser but anyway we're we're
probably doing a CrossFit workout or
some [ __ ] and this this very small
but very pretty Korean woman kind of
walks Cheeseman I lived on a I live in a
walk Street and she came walking down
the walk Street and she had like her
belongings she was holding like her
belongings she didn't even have a bag
and I thought something is wrong here
and she was in sort of that sheer feet
were very dirty and she was almost in a
nightgown and frankly she looked like
she is she had escaped something and I
looked at her and the first thing I
thought was this woman was forced into a
massage parlor somewhere and ran away
and she looked at me and I was she said
hello I said hi go are you alright and
she goes oh I I'm just a little bit lost
and like you know and I said oh and we
started talking I realized she had
nowhere to go I said do you have any
money and she but she had dignity and
she was not crazy
no and I and she looked like she was in
danger I said do you have any money and
she said no I don't have money right now
and and I said when was the last time
that you are you you have anyway I let
her come in she goes can I use your
bathroom I said yes and she looked dirty
and I said do you want to take a shower
or a bath and I was with my buddy and
she said she kind of touch to justice
thank you so much I would I would really
like that so she was in my bath for for
our boy and I and I finally I was like
what do I do
no no she was she was cleaning herself
yeah and then she came out and I
realized I go you don't have anywhere to
go I go you have no money and I remember
I gave her
five hundred dollars and did you guys
date no I just gave her five her nose
and she told me that I was an angel -
she said you're an angel and she touched
me like she touched my head on my heart
near my chest and she said you're an
angel and you saved my life and she just
disappeared I never forgot that I
[ __ ] there she goes I feel like I've
been I I saw these two beautiful men
that took me in and let me shower and
give I never forgot I came and didn't
find out this story which she wouldn't
tell me the story but I'm convinced
massage while running away from a very
bad guy I'm convinced she was running
away from a gang of some some organized
group of [ __ ] who clearly held
in Lesage hurt yeah against her will I
don't know I don't know man I never I
never ever forgot that but at least I
gave her some [ __ ] whatever that you
know whatever that those massage bothers
me hey there's that one off Wilshire I
know a couple businessman go down - oh
it drained like cow oh yeah man I Drive
by it oh my god that place I ran I ran
into a wall of mm-hmm I ran into a
straight-up celebrity and he was waiting
in line at Bryce and I go hey and he
goes hey I go what are you done because
well I'm getting that decided to get
little phone action done here but right
there I go why he goes right there is
the best massage parlor in [ __ ] in LA I
was like huh and he was pointing to this
that looks like my god you know it looks
like I'm whatever it looked like a
skinned Gilders there's an app for it
called rug maps rug maps rug rub rub rub
maps is it rub rub mats rub it might be
rub recommence rub them out yeah look up
brother driver rub map bet yeah buddy if
you don't got any Koreans in there it's
all we have there
if you don't think chin is yeah rub mats
calm you don't think chin is a
straight-up pimp and-and-and you don't
[ __ ] with his money
if you don't think Chan's taking the
money we paid from this and just getting
jacked off every night downtown LA
you're not he doesn't you don't pay for
it in paper he's getting milked like a
Korean cow every Tuesday Thursday night
crazy hñ what how do you say where's my
money [ __ ] in Korean Jin how do you say
three fingers in the ass
oh hey bro this is a family show
Jesus talk about one up on me
I mean I'm like I'm worth my money [ __ ]
Jin I say three fingers in yes three
three you know what while we're at it
how do you say three fingers you're
right exactly because no mics and I
apologize people just like zel creech
people were just driving like H in the
ass do you mind
hey I tell you what let's play three
night hide the three digits oh man
where's my money [ __ ] in Korean ton
joke eg beer pong joke is your bet yeah
don't kid you bet ya han jockeys babe
Perez my accent sounds more Japanese but
Tom your QB that's even more Korean home
dude how do you say let's get a bit I'm
in there hotties
just say how do you get a thumb in there
goddammit no thumb how about give me the
thumb how about give me the thumb you
know we use English language a lot right
so we will state thumb Jews ile nicely
to Jesus on your is it as a formal way
to get home do-do-do-do-do don't you say
oh yeah then take these four digits in
thumb just they all come to zero you can
stand my rump at the four digits but
stick that thumb let's lose the thumb -
lets go digits deep you can say digits
so yuvigi since I don't how to say
fingers all day yeah like the number you
know [ __ ] these
did you just call me brother yeah it's
for what is it naked one more time out
loud how not to sit there no net net net
negative means like I in you or I nega
nega nega rains really bad remember nega
nega nega no yeah don't say no yeah no
yeah no it's me gay
yeah no yeah I think it's me yeah [ __ ]
it means for like [ __ ] ya [ __ ] Tom
Druce here neo neo mariya come to say
how would you do it be like we're in
Korea will hard time painting
why I don't know yet I go like this this
means extra money drain me yeah
extra money drain me don't don't say
stuff like milk my dick I said milk my
tummy like a Korean cow like the stomach
turning
you're a billion will those places no
time for chump answering that question
but you look at rub maps you'll be a
real psycho to create this there'll be a
real job man these are all I actually
have never been I've never walked into
one of those place dude the ones when I
was the mayor del Rey I'd walk in a
massage parlor and on the thing would
say there are no happy endings here this
is a professional place please do not
ask you know what that means
they give happy endings really typically
yes you see that sign or if they go have
you been here before skill nope I'm new
you ain't conject ah there we go
I sure have that means you know the deal
gonna have this is all code really and I
go air for [ __ ] Wow
marina massage Thai yoga massage
no I click on the reviews I'd be lying
if I said that I I'd be lying if I said
I don't feel like going and I bet you my
wife would probably be kind of okay with
it how about that no is this one oh then
there's ratings and looks like glue
she's doing all the jacking off here I
redid your hands
oh you have to go preach and pay for
that [ __ ] do it now sorry
825 god I can't even make it out God hey
we need some fan send us your login info
so we can check this out please I can't
oh man I'd love to see some of the
comments Lu Shu is good soft hands
worked pretty fast talk a little too
much yeah there is a holy elbows man he
kind of turned me off I guess there is a
whole thing is there ever Marina del Rey
massage apartment asian massage parlor
oh so what the hell ATMs out
ass-to-mouth fingers goes from apps to
now hey I'll do B for ass ATM to mouth
menstruation period oh here you go Brian
hey B you need to go there and ask for a
baby back
it's a petite young attractive Asian man
I do in the man isn't what is it you
want a baby back when you go say yeah
how's you be me on all fours all Asian
gotta be back I want a small Asian guy
oh here you go
you want a BB JTC a bareback blow job to
completion in mouth whoa
yeah yeah or maybe you wanna be be be
blue and no de l'épée when you go there
go i'd like a baby back with a BB JTC
and qns a bareback blow job to
completion no quit no spit oh my god ah
there's what I'm looking for a BBB jwf a
bareback [ __ ] with a facial Lord have
him and I'd like to do it BCD behind
clothes I don't want like what if I put
my dong in her mouth after she gave
somebody after she gave somebody a
bareback [ __ ] to completion with
swallow if she gets up a guy a BB oh
this is what you WS your birthday's
coming up you didn't get you well I want
to get you a baby back
the BDSM accompanied by a BSL a BLS is a
ball licking suckin what about it can I
get a butterface
everything with butterface do you want a
baby backer do you want BSB a bus stop
babe it's your birth what's a bus stop
babe well it's a babe hangs on bus stops
also has a lot lizard oh no there's a
runaway otherwise no it's an underage
runaway no thank you I'll see you me
tough to get rid of yeah you're right
she has a lot of free time once the
chill wants to buy her shoes yeah a bus
stop babe
I beat what for your for your birthday
we'll get you some of these you sure you
don't want to see this a covered doggy
style how about a cache and - Rob who
takes your money and then runs covered
[ __ ] BJ with a condom no thanks full
service provider costing 200 hours or
less crossdresser whoa covered doggy
style covered what does that mean ooo I
gotta cover my dog oh oh but if you're
cruising like are you gonna be cruising
on your birthday you know a cruise it
means now cruise is a slang for driving
around looking for streetwalkers carpet
matches drapes typically a natural
blonde but there's just a digital anal
probe finger and anus there you go
dining at the O analingus dining at the
they at the Y cunnilingus oh you need a
baby bag DDG a baby back drop-dead
gorgeous
yeah man behind curls on hands oh here
we go birthday special you want a baby
back dee dee GDP which is well you want
a baby back was a small young man you
want you want a DD g which is drop-dead
gorgeous but then you also want a DT
which is a deep throat and tireless the
penis is taken into the mouth and then
what you want a drawer is a fi a fingers
in the ass and FIA FIA it's your
birthday we had a girl one time tell me
that she could she could go take it all
the way in and then I was like oh well
that's gonna be hard for me to get out
of my mind and we would hang out and
talk and one day she got drunk and I was
a little drunk I don't really drink and
then we went to my place in Venice and
she goes good
going let's get it going I was like hey
you want and then she pulled out she
goes told you and I was like well you
can't just stop there no hellos like
sorry I got a boyfriend
hey what maybe for your birthday do you
mind if I hit you a frog upin cooter
what is that a haiku poem coup Thawra
German Bravo
it's a German broth oh boy I filled with
anything so much it's very confused
pulling peanuts very confusing [ __ ] gets
weird yeah yeah I don't know about that
that's where a GU girl like you can get
your daughter gue girls now a cool girl
you don't know [ __ ] sound good
Noel you can use your imagination I'm
impressed with all these different than
me two-minute I can't get enough clean
shaven kitty hardwood hardwood floors
you call it she got a hardwood floor
I'll clean shaven you don't beat for
your birthday how about I get your hdh
man what's that you have to ask can't
afford it oh [ __ ] it's a high-dollar
hottie ah [ __ ] that's good
you know what um you want me get your
birthday an Italian I know just thing
and telling Bert yeah sure like at a
lien is a penis rubbing between butt
cheeks well come on bro let me get you a
nice Italian with a baby face I don't
know I mean yeah but then I want to get
in there yo you he's getting in there
what I mean he's getting inside the box
no matter what somebody did to me not
your floor in foam hey why am i facedown
on this mat it smells like Playtex oh
these are great
one time I had a girlfriend and she went
down on me and she goes you've been
wearing a condom and I go no I haven't
she was you cheated on me and yet I kind
of my go well first of all I did good
thing I used to count him a second well
that's not true
she was your foolish [ __ ] this is a girl
you're dating yep or it might have been
my wife now let me finish let me finish
and I kill me we've got tense for a
second there and I was trying to explain
I was like no that's not what happens
I've been back from the road and she
goes well you got some splaining to do
and I realized that I had been enough
without maid gloves I had been
we had a rubber football that had been
in the Sun in Calabasas and it gets
really hot there and the rubber had had
powdered that the rubber powder I held
it I swear to God oh yeah I was throwing
it for the dog okay and then I went to
pee and I peed in touch so I I detected
it myself and I had to bring the
football in and go here you go smell
this and leave my face right listen
Amanda bye yes ain't nobody here bye
what the [ __ ] what do you have skeptical
hippo eyes there did you take that ball
and rub your dick all over it I mean I
also used a condom but the point is this
cuz I've eaten chicken wings head sauce
all over my hands took a piss my dick
didn't smell like hot sauce well my dad
came in one time and had lipstick on his
pocket like hey [ __ ] you got
lipstick on your [ __ ] pocket and he
goes well I don't know how I got there
and she goes well that's a problem
yeah [ __ ] and did he say I was
getting a BB he was back in the day when
you got tickets you know hard tickets
from the counter and it had the red dye
on it and he had it in his pocket and
she found the ticket she wiped it on a
certain she's like that's the red - did
your mom buy that excuse she's I'm not
figured it off my dad would never in a
million years I told you uh in the
locker rooms the fellas talk where I've
come o'clock rooms and this guy used to
have a girl and he wasn't or Singh known
for cheating on his girl left and right
and she would smell his dick when he'd
come home at night yeah I've had a
girlfriend
let me smell your dick I had a
girlfriend his dad and she would
literally cup his genitals and smell his
dick Wow she better have a good sniffer
on her
you have a good sniffer a good old
sniffer that's why you gotta wash your
dick off in the sink we all have in the
sink sure you get up on your toes put
your dong in there water's cold
I'll do you one dirtier or you just slip
the water from the urinal cover your
wiener when have you done that I've
never done that world of guys doing that
yes can we don't ever do that let's
approach missin weights rub map
you're trying it's your birthday I'm
trying to get your be DSP Italia
knowledge eyes everybody should we break
down some of the fights coming up if you
want but for your birthday what do you
want to do me you want me to get your
BDDs D QRS or no with Italians
with a babyface no I can't do that I'm
just going to dinner
yeah well go to dinner I told you I use
I use that massage app company and they
sent over just this just I mean you
wanna test my patience they sent to
assess your results if that did the
dimepiece chocolate dream team like
Darwin okay man that's a problem came at
you and we're gonna set up I went bring
the extra bedroom about how about on
this dick yeah yeah chocolate dream just
not like this a nightmare keep your
mouth shut
do you electric cash give you a little
extra cash we'll let you cash yeah I'm
talking like a ten came to my door music
alright what's going on here we should
perfect super professional
I'm the best massage I've ever had wow
that was nice man oh man
tough not to have an interaction I'm
gonna give your balls a little tug here
if you don't mind you know when they get
that yeah you know chank chank yeah I
thought it was I thought they were
trying to test and I thought maybe Joe
set it up you know yeah right but then I
talked in code to see you know I went uh
dog like an Italian she was I don't know
what that is all right we're good you're
legit how about a BB D how do you have a
baby face of DD judge to completion she
said no she went I have no idea what
your time I write this is legit god I
almost is I bet you they have to deal
with that all my gosh oh that sure like
I would never [ __ ] I'd first I don't
want to make her feel weird also I don't
want to be that [ __ ] creep even
though I am you will night when you get
massaged there you go go ahead and
change what you're comfortable I don't
go butt-naked
I usually my shorts on my undies on the
guys who go butt-naked that's always
suspect dude people are so paranoid
onset now like I was just on set and
this really sweet guy he's a veteran and
he's our he does he does he's crew he's
part of the crew
he's such a nice guy and he said you
know he's been he was the military a
long times I'm so lucky I get free
breakfast I get to work with these bro
cuz I get to work with these pretty and
he pointed to one of the makeup women
she's beautiful what are these pretty
into guys sorry sorry I didn't mean it
you guys you called me pretty
and I said yeah and I am too it's fine
you know but he was so scared she this
is what we're at always paranoid nothing
dude it's all good no no I told you the
cops tried touch that girl right before
she's not on stage she's a beast
and I went I grabbed her elbow when
we're backstage I might love your coat
no please don't
the police don't get me in trouble I
didn't mean it like that I'm not creepy
man please don't
I think that's sorry yeah yeah yeah what
can you do it's all good it's all good
once I send me on a massage chin I don't
get massages remember you're tense like
my brother hit yeah MJ was this time you
got a massage really you've never had
one I'm gonna buy you a massage MJ I
think this just in me and Brian will
give you the last do you want an MBO trm
VBR whatever you want whatever you want
or a Monty maybe you wanna MS oh gee oh
yeah multiple pops multiple releases
Jesus Christ P do you know how massage
um feel like for girls I should because
my back might like really part of my
back I can't even feel the nerve damage
I mean like I need like strong hands I
had a massage once oh I'll get you a
russian chick boy your mind
one time we went to this 20 dollar
massage place about Jefferson and
something in Culver City and the guy
like scoop me so creepy like this old
Asian dude I went with one of my
girlfriends and guy friends shouldn't
look so uncomfortable no you saw hi well
no I need get like a good way I got a
strong time she got Massage Envy there's
some legit misuses there or the one at
the house they come to the crib it's
actually better awesome in that
chocolate dream and she won't [ __ ]
blow your mind yeah yeah cuz you got
dense you got a dense body so I oh they
don't work you need some savior they
they they burn yeah
oh they're sweating home yeah you got
you got a [ __ ] lot of thick muscle
you gotta get into that ass is on my
lower backs yeah how often is people I
mean I got a weekend a woman a small
woman massaging I only do women really
yes but have you added them get in there
so I can get oh yeah like that user
elbows in their eyes I'm right you know
Dan Henderson's already can kill her
Mariah can kill it I've had Mariah
it's just Tiger Woods personal massager
I perceive she's she's awesome but
she'll bring the pain I like Mariah
she's I've had some little like Korean
girls get in there deep she's not over
all on my back and get their in their
their heels and yeah yeah she said
working on Dan Henderson is like working
on would ya he's so strong his so dense
she works with everyone when they say
that Henderson is like wrestlers are
notoriously strong and this is wrestling
strong then there's Dan Henderson he's
weird strong but you need to get one my
yoga studio we have a thai Yoga Massage
please Thai massages is all right but
people will come in asking for happy
endings like 100 percent people about
happy endings here's my thing with this
hashtag no creepy hashtag no me too is
there a difference between a pleasurable
foot massage your scalp massage and then
getting your penis massage I'll tell you
why there's a difference cuz your penis
your scalp and your feet
don't shoot out oh right [ __ ] load
everywhere I know pleasure in it it is
but you know this thing about your dick
you know why cuz I've come I know but
why white white white why is it saying
wow I understand the question you're
asking if you want pleasure it's awful
it's all pleasure like you know if I
want to go get drinks ice cream drinks I
can get 15 drinks you've hammered
following it a [ __ ] you know a sax
has always come with all kinds of
responsibilities because that was how
disease was spread that's how children
were born sex has always been a very but
I gotta find your HGH double to double
qw RS the Italian Job well let's take a
let's take a guy in a movie so you could
have a guy when you write a TV show or a
movie if that guy cheats on his wife
he's a bad guy
no matter what there
tell you to change it even though it
might be a really complicated character
only TV shows to get away with it is
like Tony Soprano he just got away with
it very Riggs also oh yeah he's also
gangster what but that's a lack of
self-control right right for better for
some men have a have a predilection do
they want [ __ ] they want a lot of
different women okay but they might love
their wife but they want you know they
want to step outside that's a form of a
that's a lack of self-control right not
unlike eating too much
not unlike gambling not unlike drinking
the sort of same thing though it's all
the same it's all the same we are way
they're all vying those other vices and
not forgiving it all of the of the guy
who just can't keep it in his pants and
it's just interesting and it's always
been that way sex is okay though
your dick is very similar to a gun it's
very--it's but always been a fair and
more though so than ever in 2018 it's
just interesting it's it's always been
that way but it's and it's never even it
pretty silly when you think of any when
you get to the nitty-gritty of it well
the one thing I think is interesting
about I was thinking about this like how
a lot of it is being characterized as
men have power over women that's
actually not true beautiful women have a
shitload of power over men men do crazy
super gorgeous we're not in Hollywood
but yeah even in Hollywood I mean not
Sharon Stone believe me she hurt her she
had a great response did you ever sell
and start laughing yeah but Sharon Stone
when she was younger had a great deal of
power to every man in Hollywood want to
have sex with her and she was also good
at her acting and stuff and though she
had to deal with that she also had a lot
of power herself and ultimately became
very wealthy because of it so it all
depends but um but it's just funny man
it's funny how yeah we're not forgiving
of that one vice which is strength I
cute like if you see a guy coming out of
a jackoff parlor like oh well really
it's like I mean yeah guys guys get it I
think maybe because women can suffer
from gambling and suffer from eating
disorders can suffer from all those
things but half the population doesn't
get when you really can't keep it in
your pants like that's that's because
they they're gonna side with the woman
because they probably had it done to
them there's a lot of problems with it
the men's oh well if you write a TV show
they're going to go win
women hate you I wrote a script and the
guy cheating on his girl on the script
and the women I gave to to read said I
stopped reading after that and I thought
that was really understand Wow
[ __ ] it wasn't gonna show you're
going for watch a million shows with the
guy cheats on the girl
matter of fact every show I watch as the
guy cheat my girl who most of them
narcos El Chapo yeah they are they're
all gangsters yeah they're gay already
compromised but but even in the others I
mean you know if you watch if you watch
ballers yeah but I can watch athletes
athletes in these shows though yeah it's
really yeah very very full that's new to
you know that's actually kind of new
Tony Soprano probably assured that in if
you look at most of it like even on
Breaking Bad that dude does all kinds of
bad things but he never touches a woman
you know about his wife yes kids but but
it's it's it's a it's very dicey
territory dramatically whenever you you
pitch that in a room very dicey very
dicey she's just some current events you
want to talk fine so chin just yeah so
chin just doesn't want massages MJ needs
one yeah
and it's your birthday so I feel like
you need an Italian job yeah yeah for my
birthday what it's my birthday
someone give us your account for a rub
Matt so we can find County good bday
gift yeah I want a nice sturdy handsome
young Korean man to give you Italian
just don't feel comfortable with the man
board here's nice just know I don't know
man I just don't
what's your name chin oh so close to
home man you're tall
it is chin um are you uh what's up I'll
be in Boston for the fights brother
going to the fight you will I'm excited
about that you'll be at the Wilbur I
want to put some money down and I want
to add and and for the first time and
I'm gonna have to pick your brain only
16 grandma carry on now you know I have
for this you want to go right to the
main car do you want to you want to
start with the other fights are awful
let's just do the ironing Co well
Cormier O's Damaris that B's real main
event
yeah be the Commandant I think that's an
awful fight to be honest you do be
cuz O's mears a high-level striker and
you think that Daniel is gonna put them
on us back I don't think those two
mirrors at that upper level like a DC I
think DC can play it safe avoid the big
punch which he's done against Rumble
which he's done against John Jones and
take folk him down and just make it not
that fun of a fight yeah I don't think
that's a great fight
I actually think belt door has a better
card this weekend I think Steve pavers
Francis is the best fight of the weekend
yeah but I think overall Bellator with
Douglas Lima and Roy MacDonald and Pico
and Chandler and Chael they have a
better card yeah well I got um steep a
in this fight really I sure do for a
couple I bet you but you only 16 grand
for a couple of reasons one is I think
Steve Bay is a better boxer and I think
that in Ghana is is incredibly
devastating because he swings wide and
hard but if steep I can stand on the
edge of the pocket he's get better
wrestler he could double leg him all day
take him down the match is a double leg
him all day and the last iced tea based
double looked even attempted well he's
still a d1 wrestler and you're right he
never used his wrestling but that's
because he knocks everybody out from
from ver doom to I mean he knocks
literally everybody out Loski over him
yeah he's not I mean it's unbelievable
and I think he's so good at being able
to stay on the edge of the pocket he's a
really good boxer and I see him standing
out there stepping back and blasting
Gamow and if he doesn't knock him out he
wrestles them and tires him out I think
the plan would be to wrestle em I would
what if I'm him
give me around if I'm him first round I
take that [ __ ] dude down and I wear
him out because he's cuz I'm got on that
you're suturing you're assuming yeah
that Francis can't wrestle I am assuming
that you're assuming I am that Francis
actually fought a better wrestler and
they get taken down I'm you're assuming
that people say Francis actually goes
the Olympic team doesn't get taken down
I've heard that too
heard that too I would bet you but you
only too much money so are you going
with Francis and God
I am it pains me to say I'm rooting for
steep a but I just don't see it in fur
for this reason at and with heavy
weights you could technically say steep
a is a better technical boxer but it
doesn't really matter when you're 265
pounds you're cutting 265 in your
Francis the technique you can get away
with being a little more sloppy when you
do the hardest puncher in the world yeah
so for steep a steep aids biggest issue
is steep a doesn't use angles and steep
it goes north to south he never goes
angles east to west he always goes
forwards
oh well with a guy like Francis you
can't really there's no room for air so
steep a and every fight gets hit if the
last row room fight got robbed yeah drop
yeah Orlovsky you know you got hit JDS
he got hit many of times yeah well with
Francis you can't you just can't can't
get any pay will trade one for one well
Francis that doesn't work yeah
you can't play that gap so I don't think
steep a for 25 minutes can play that one
for one and get out of there live but I
will say this I think if the fight goes
past maybe way through the second round
steep a wins that fight because Frank
has canceled it's not early yeah no I
don't I don't think frets can get tired
I think you know Steve a gets tired too
but I I think steep a is gonna have a
hell of a time taking them down and I
think from the sheer like power that
Francis has like when Elster tried to
wrap them up and got Swiss ran you can
see the panic announcers face he's like
what though he's and I felt strong like
he's crazy stupid strong yeah and he
doesn't have the best technique but it
doesn't matter at heavyweight really it
doesn't hit so hard yeah Alistair
Overeem has better technique than steep
a ver doom Francis at that worked out
for matter de France actually over him
actually throwing more precise punches
mm-hmm Francis through from down here it
just yeah just swung I I hope you're
right I hope I'll actually hope CP wins
and then we get out d basic technically
a better fighter
why you say Zack nicly why's why better
boxing better wrestling right God
Almighty have better takedown but might
have to kind of take down defense that
makes it impossible to take him down I
don't know well
so I think ste pays a better overall
well-rounded fighter but that doesn't
mean he's a better fighter
when stipa has that god-given power way
got me worried yeah whoever wins at this
point yeah also but thing that bombs
Matt steep is he's had a lot of freaking
battles man said a lot of wars and you
hear him talking it's you know really
yeah
I feel like most of his fights have been
mouth you've seen the JDS fights that
was did you see olds room where he got
knocked on yeah yeah yeah but but that
how long that lasts that lasted was that
last two rounds like all the rights or
does it matters one round it doesn't
well hold on we say they're not long
fights would mean not long fights time
at the 10 round yeah that's crows were
ones that are long but everything else
has been so JDS was um first round when
he knocked out Julius but the overing
one was the end of the the first round
yeah so so these have been short fights
I don't think he took as much beating
Purdue was very close right but here's
the last here's the prom be so he don't
say he didn't take much beating when you
get knocked unconscious to have to pop
up it doesn't matter whether it was in
the fifth or the first round yeah brain
traumas brain trauma in other words your
chin gets more glassy it's just these
huge punches you're eating his biggest
wars were the the JDS which is the one
that woody lost which I thought he won
that was a big one for him yeah and then
that you know he smoked Marty bleeding
it hit mark hunt
smoked Arlovski smoke for Doom Ostrow
roommate had some damage when the fight
Junior dos Santos just Merck junior to
Santos yeah but it's just a different
animal yeah what's his training camp
like Steve base versus in Ghana Chris
McDonald trains at the UFC trade center
and yeah he flies back to France with
his home team okay and what you mean as
far as soozee training with yeah yeah
who does steeple Francis but you know
he's always kind of trained he's a
trained with Weidman those guys you
think okay well yeah but it doesn't
matter you know there it means world
champion yeah whatever he's doing he's
doing his work yeah
yeah smart fighter I don't know it'd be
interesting I see I went consider Steve
a smart fighter he wouldn't know I would
not comply but I consider Cain a smart
fighter why one doesn't get hit steep
eight gets hit mm-hmm if stiva if
steeper will rush in there and get hit
and he pull played that game yeah but
you know and he doesn't use a lot of
level changes he doesn't use his
grappling name the last guy he took down
no he doesn't take it I don't know and
just knocks dudes out question is how is
it question is can he take and gone on
out so who is so so France and Ghana
fought you're saying the better wrestler
was a sovereign no Curtis blades JUCO
national champion and but lights
couldn't take him down had prawns but I
mean this is back in the day you know
this year's like his first or second UFC
fight yeah it did there's a lot of
questions with that you know an anti
Hampton was Division one wrestler Curtis
blaze national champion it's a
fascinating fight you know and I am
curious because in the grand scheme of
things Francis really hasn't done much
he merked arlovski mert mert over him
who were both long in the tooth like not
like he's beating a prime J BS which
steep a did right it's not like he
merked a Mark Hunt who still has a great
chin true you know so true there's all
these X factors and maybe it's the only
thing is it I wonder how much like I
feel like he has so much momentum like
his confidence is probably sky-high
hi Steve Bay's got to be thinking about
how what a liability that power is I
don't think so no I think Stevie Stevie
feels disrespected they's an underdog is
a champion oh it's a fascinating fight
yeah
[ __ ] yeah I hope you're right beef I
mean how do you as a heavyweight with
that kind of power can you cover up can
you parry I mean with those small gloves
and what if he swings is the idea to
stay can you stand in his grill and kind
of like you gotta get under lock you got
to get on there yeah you gotta get what
under hook you have to close the gap
there's no there's no exchanges there's
no exchange so if you're Steve babe
all there's notes your honor iPod
heavyweight there's really no extinct a
you either the edge of the pocket or you
got a no either out or you're in okay
there's no in-between sweats with
Francis so [ __ ] I think that over him
over he was doing decently as [ __ ] I'm
swing from the hips and gets [ __ ]
annihilated yeah you just don't play
that game not with I don't think steep I
play that game I you know I do think see
doesn't be in and out but it's just a
matter of time we're you know Steve babe
well play with that danger zone and with
Frances I just don't think there's a lot
of room for error it's scary for a guy
like Steve Bay who generally Jen
generally doesn't have a lot of head
movement yeah
eBay is very plot II yeah huge head yeah
huge head good chin ah but I don't think
good Chin's matter when you're fine
Francis I feel like let's Franciscan
again we don't know much about Francis
Francis could be all hype Francis could
land that big shot it doesn't knock ste
payouts TPA keeps going forward in
France like oh [ __ ] and we see him
crumble we see we see him break although
with his history and being homeless and
his father being a world-renowned street
fighter in Africa on the streets of
Cameroon I would say I would assume
Francis has some pretty mental topple
well according to Rogen he trains like a
[ __ ] beast like I'm gone off that
doesn't mean anything to me no oh he
trains hard yeah everyone on the roster
trains very very hard well you know I
don't know you know I'm saying by this
like Steve I train hard yeah
see buddy trains like a beast yeah DC
trains like a beast most admire trains
like a beast yeah what's that mean ya
know dude but he's hitting the pads hard
they all hit pads very hard yeah oh you
know it's the marriage the only guy who
would spar with Anthony Johnson he's the
only guy who'd go in there spices Christ
and go blow for blow with Jesus really
so but you know I'm saying would be like
dude he's such a beast
I hate and I've heard that from Francis
but yeah all these guys I mean why don't
we do is an absolute nightmare in the
gym yeah isn't freak and weather do you
trance Mart there's a lot of factors
yeah a lot of factors but you know the
UFC you know they just did the whole
bane thing you know with with Francis
and they're trying to hype this Francis
train up so you can see why Stevie feels
a little disrespected mm-hmm
you're right but I hope Stephen goes in
and does work I think him and a cane
match up is what we need but yeah I want
to see that I really want to see Cain
John John how much on John's to come
back clean and I want the super fight
Jon Jones Cain Velasquez J needs to
fight right twice before then yes so
long yeah yeah but I'd love to see that
too dude [ __ ] I hope you're right man
well see buddy yeah I think DC gets us
you're gonna be the cage side yeah B
Kate sent I think DC's gets a crown
submission over Asda man really you
think those ruins no I think DC puts him
on his back yeah and where's the Magnus
you know most American looking really
good he's uh I don't know his pedigree
is a high-level striker hi yep
so DC's just too smart I think to play
that game with no time mm-hmm rest
guarding [ __ ] and then Bellator you got
jail rampage
chills in there yesterday jails in shape
looks good huh looks good
he's awesome he was tired he won't tell
you he's tired on chin yeah but he woke
up after you started talking yeah he's
great for he was just yeah really yeah
he has mom and his uncle it was pretty
cool to see him here to fight and
rampage
I know Wow crazy right yeah he's a
heavyweight tournament so if he wins
that fight he fights the winner Frank
Mir phaidor like dude those guys are so
big he's like now figure it out jeez you
never know what fate or you know it
frankly I mean you're right 260 more
than that actually
yeah and chills not that big yeah chills
to jump on 185 yeah he fights at 214
though he's cutting weight still too he
say he just feels natural him to cut
some sort of way to the otherwise I'm
feel he's getting in a fight
that's incredible he's funny right he's
amazing his skills though who knows I
think what about what do you think of
the Rory MacDonald had a great fight it
was a giant Leamas burnett a knockout
artist what's that I've had Lima in here
it's funny because with Lima
belt or goes hey we want to give you
your own MacDonald and Lima I go you
know I know a fleam up I'm like I'll
just take Rory like no please do both so
Roy comes in does its thing like always
good and then Douglas Lima comes in and
he stole the show man he was great
really he's great amazing story saying
really like it's right there you can
click on that thing's gonna take it to a
different thing yeah really man Wow
and and just have just confident just a
nice kid yeah now looks like a bug but
knocked out artists super cool as the
most not you know he's the best knockout
artist in Bellator history he just feels
like he doesn't hasn't got the respect
that he deserves being as high level as
he is what do you think here if you have
to put where's the smart model it's
tough to bet against Roy McDonald man
Roy Eric dollar is the best welterweight
on the planet you know he beat Woodley
would you know especially the way Roy he
looked against Paul Daley but this is
definitely Roy stuffs Fighting's quite
some time damn good cards all the same
night right yeah yeah give me it's very
good because that that that UFC paper
you isn't that strong besides those two
fights they're not strong at all and
then you have free belt or which is a
banger on paramount team Network which
is their lot did no more Spike right
it's just Bear Mountain at work now yeah
so they're launching this big card for
free so I wonder how many pavers that
steals from the UFC cuz if you're just a
general fight fan yeah really not in
francis's you don't know who owes
Damaris steep eight can take or leave DC
I get like him when he fights John Jones
the rest card I don't know
while it's free I know jail and a
rampage I know Roy McDonald I don't
Michael Chandler you know so it's me
interesting the numbers I think the
numbers will suffer for the UFC really I
do i I don't think they break it be very
this day if they do their play their
cards right the day that Bellator beats
the UFC well don't beat them Saturday
they'll beat them overall view Saturday
but once free and once pay-per-view now
if they're both pay-per-view god it'd be
close this card yeah yeah I'd be
interesting a lot of competition I mean
I think it's good 100% it's good a
hundred percent if you reward your
fighters you're gonna get some of the
best ones are gonna go over there
excited for the fights this week good
enough
belt or doesn't have to deal I'm not
saying any but belt or does enough to
deal with the kind of drug testing that
UFC does right now it's based off state
state commission you know there's still
drug test but no not like you saw them
though I'd you thought at all all right
just great events chin yep
Oh Aaron Pico though yeah now I want to
see that kid she's last night tough yeah
he had a tough one
no no no you not be first first fight
the math squirt gun fight yeah yeah yeah
you know you should see this up right
after that really did he look and say oh
my god he's he knocked this dude out so
bad uppercut was so vicious he's been
doing it since he he was wrestling
international level at 16 years old you
know that it's weird
yeah he's the little next Lord big thing
looks everybody forty at this that's
tough on your face Lord that kid I mean
how old is he now
2020 look at his face Felix 20 yeah I
mean I I mean he thinks of me if he was
revived with electricity I mean I mean
if his left out in the Sun his face
looks like a baseball I mean in all due
respect that kids been through some [ __ ]
man he boxes out wild boxing yeah that's
uh yeah Wow I mean looks like a young
Frank Shamrock does look like Frank room
to be such Frank Shamrock he's so used
to winning is a maas you can see but you
can see video of him wrestling at 16
years old up to you on an international
role there's video him wrestling it
likes I don't know but I'm saying
wrestling like Russian well 30 yeah and
and doing work though he's a monster at
16 there's a prodigy properties are
LeBron James a product yeah hundred
percent and is he fighting a 45 or 50 45
40 lungs worried that last guy he
knocked out so [ __ ] bad not that well
now hold on hold for a second go back to
that place okay back to that yes now
that guy
Modelling Wrangler jeans who is that
guys that Tommy T is that John Fogerty
from Clearwater Revival who is that guy
civilian with the long hair he's only
the lead singer of trade yes
I'm Freeman who's the guy who's the 46
year old together I've [ __ ] up Pecos
debut oh yes yeah he's six and oh yeah
that guys are real that guy's like a
real veteran yep yeah but he's just six
- no but in way bigger Petersham in
finding that weight class but also yeah
I asked captain Scott Coker I went dude
why would you give peak oh that guy goes
pika wants someone even more qualified
than that no one will find him everyone
turn the fight down and see only gather
take the fight Wow
heavier six fights six and I'll Pecos
like I'll take it I guess
he wanted more yeah but I tell you what
if crazy Bob cooked cosine Joon crazy
Bob cooked cosine hook our boy Pico here
that means he's legit yeah hi Jim what
could a man she a brother all right the
first one is that it's just an update on
the hmm mom that little kid that did the
ad for H&M had a sweater on that said
coolest monkey in the jungle
his mom is actually like saying to the
people that are giving them crap like
it's not a big deal you guys are crying
wolf like relax
yeah like chill out yeah I agree and but
I didn't p-diddy offer this kid a full
modeling contract now don't know about
that I'm pretty sure I think he did he
was this about this he'd there was that
because he had that sweatshirt do you
hear about this Brian no this was like
an H&M ad and the kid was just wearing
this sweater and then all these
celebrities mostly black slivers are
coming out saying like this is crap and
they changed a picture to look like he's
the king there was a history of yeah but
I mean there was a huge backlash you
don't know we did this with field yeah
yeah we did when Theo was here so they
came out with a picture of a little
black boy like this or white boy yeah
and his says coulis monkey in the jungle
yeah I could have told you that was
gonna happen
Yeah right do you find it racist no I
mean I don't think anybody was trying to
be racist there I think you're sloppy
it's sloppy I would if
if I was on iPhoto should I said excuse
me no can't do that
how does it slip through or are they
still not racist the moms are it's a
little bit since she's already talking
she's right but this she got back I cost
my son a monkey yeah but there's a
history it is you know it's gonna happen
you gotta you gotta do bad you don't
know well you gotta know people are
gonna but then you know the rap artist
gez hears his own blind with hm this was
come out and he just dropped the deal
was like because you guys were so sloppy
with us it looks racist I'm out the
weekend - there - huge huge stars big
blunder on H an expert yeah alright
that's that so the mom actually was
getting crap about it to you cuz oh
there it is he did he set off for hm
child cotton R a storm a 1 million
dollar modeling contract there you go
things really worked out a lot of good
things worked out yeah but hmm got
screwed all right so everyone has seen
this by now right no no this is crazy so
car that ended up in the second story of
a building which was a dentist's office
and this looks unbelievable right this
fast and fierce Evan so there's footage
of this and this is actually in Santa
Ana my Parenthood yeah yes a couple of
videos so the first video came out and
this is the first video surveillance at
a lab okay on crash Southern California
look at this police say Oh jumps the
center divider and crashes into the side
of all right this happened in Santa you
hit that medium and then the car as you
saw when it okay so you see this so the
car jumps the second floor why is the
building fish the car crazy is that
right off that bill he was on narcotics
two people in there because all these
admitted asses minor injuries so he
suffered minor injuries
yes that's it both survived one person
actually was able to climb out but
stayed there and one person had to be
rescued [ __ ] that's Henning he just
admitted I was on narcotics
by Batman I was on meth that we could
jump the house yeah so there was a
speculate why oh sorry would you say
there's a car that passed by after he
hit the thing so that was actually a
commuter
that had a dash cam you can see the
video here oh let's see that oh dude how
crazy I get it down right into the car
got a Civic gin I think it's an Altima
or something like that's incredible
yeah Trebek but no one got well no one
got seriously hurt so that's good no
I'll kill had insurance ain't gonna be
pretty with that yeah all right
God what was he smoking to jump hard
narcotics I think it has to be like some
sort of pain pills that's like drinking
and doing pain pills smoke and meth
smoking dope or that what else you got
all my narcotics in Japan it happened
again so there was a false missile alert
in Japan how crazy is this man so
japan's nhk which is a natural eleven
it's a Public Broadcasting Network they
did the same thing where they put on TV
oh sorry on their websites and on the
phones that North Korea had a missile
coming towards no one has skeptical
hippo oil right with all this stuff I
don't what do you think you think it's
down do you think if them just trying to
like I think that that I think actually
these things have been set up recently
and these are the glitches that happen
right I think that these are the
glitches like this has not always been
the case and now they have this new
system set up and and these are the
growing pains these are the glitches
they're always glitches right it's all
human error you see veneer when you
[ __ ] just a little scary that they're
doing these things well when you see
what we used to like the kind of
maintenance we used to have on our
Trident or was Titan Titan two missiles
that that had that packed I think a
thousand times the amount of bomb power
that that the nuclear bomb over
Hiroshima that killed one hundredth of a
prized a hundred thousand people in a
second did the Titan twos were the most
powerful missiles in the u.s. arsenal
and they were in these giant silos there
were 90 feet tall and the stories of the
eighteen and nineteen year old guys who
were responsible for keeping them close
to them and it was constant maintenance
and there was
sitting on massive amounts of jet fuel
essentially and the guy they'd have to
go and fix things and the guy who
dropped the wrench and it landed and
blew a hole into the side of it and jet
fuel started past long story short it
blew up couple um were killed it blew up
and they found the warhead a quarter
mile away
they found the quarter mount that
warhead that could destroy that could
kill you know ten million people in a
ditch
now they basically were like it's
impossible for to go off but it got shot
into the sky and it was a quarter mile
away and then they talked to some other
people they're like well it's not
impossible that it could have gone game
over and where's that at so we're in
Nevada yeah and and they had or
somewhere like New Mexico and they had
they had it under massive amounts of
concrete and when that thing blew the
concrete went all over the place and
that missile head blew out and just er
did that job yeah yeah yeah chin just
real quick
so this is how they responded a niche
case said the mistake was a result of an
error by a staff member who was
operating the alert system for online
news but yeah didn't elaborate that was
it I feel like there's something really
no it's human error people are not as
convenient I think I think actually you
have zero skeptical what I think what I
think people would be for surprise hat
is just how unorganized the government
is including the CIA including would you
not you it doesn't raise some eyebrows
to you be that all of them are getting
those nuclear warnings right me I don't
know that in this two days apart it did
I don't know maybe it's a little scary
to me yeah I'm scared it is interesting
a Donald Trump he did that missile test
in the White House and his the doctor
for the White House said that he
actually had a perfect score on his
cognitive test this is all hype that
he's crazy shut up shut up also [ __ ]
hole like I know I'm not a fan of Trump
okay you know that know what I've never
been a fan of from day one I just
thought he was I always think
[ __ ] whole countries like there are a
lot of [ __ ] hotels in this town in this
country - like that [ __ ] that that's not
what I whether it is racist or not isn't
unhistorical you can't see as the
president United States you can't see we
shouldn't let these people in from this
[ __ ] well I think that he was
probably talking privately to people
going you know why do we have these
people coming in from [ __ ] all countries
coming I'm coming in from other
countries that was more that that that
might have been an off-the-cuff thing I
don't think that's that is something
that we've all said like [ __ ] -
[ __ ] country doesn't mean I think
all Africa I don't want my present a
talk or think like that I think all
presidents talk like like you know but
didn't you see like he would rather have
more people from Norway or something
like that on top of all that I think
what he's not he's not an eloquent guy
again I'm not a fan of Trump I'm just
not there are there are things to
criticize Trump about and I could fill a
book but like when you say something
like that my guess with that [ __ ] guy
is what he's saying is that is that we
have a lot of people coming into this
country that are don't have skillsets
this is an old argument okay then we
don't we have a lot of people that are
not educated there are a lot of people
with high education high skill sets that
can't get into the country okay because
they're there because I guess there's a
lottery and and he's like why don't we
bring in people who are highly skilled
and highly educated from places like
Norway a rich developed country then a
place like Haiti so they see you're all
white people no you're always gonna get
what you're gonna get that right you're
gonna get that you're gonna get the
minute you say Norway which is very
white versus hey the only way just know
that you're gonna that in this climate
nobody wants to I'll tell you I'm not
biased as the president was six foot
three and weigh 239 pounds my ass he is
the same height weight as me my [ __ ]
away ass there's no crazy if he's not
6-3 300 but he might have been but his
natural weight might because he played
basketball when he was younger he might
have been really skinny like he's not a
big muscular guy and I think that's all
fat so he might be a natural young man
young mister get those done I guarantee
you he's not 239 pen they wouldn't lie
about that they can't lie about that
yeah they can
here's gotta seis tell the doctor that
works in the white house tells us our
president is healthy and has perfect
bread a lot of people involved in that
process I don't know that that's all
that there be other things to lie about
right the well they said that he had
really good genetics and that's y'all
genetics
he has incredibly good genes and that's
just the way God made him
oh yeah that's a real letter legit
doctor that's a legit doctor they did
say he was overweight but that didn't
say was a obese or anything but a little
overweight he looks pretty fat to me
there's no ways to I give you see him
sitting down on a golf course he's a
he's a fatty fat man you have steel
fattest asses he's a good guy he's so
big me get bring him bring him up bring
up Rio just put in skinny Donald Trump
when he's young young skinny Donald
Trump put that in I want to see
something I'm have to pee real soon here
go for it
don't see one there is Regan big dude oh
yeah he's no I there's no way he's
turned 39 pounds I don't know I better
go people I mean see him in a suit man
in his pants there's just no way
what he got how about this that Brian
just saw a fisherman Sue's after a
dramatic boat crash call you and scared
just look at this I just brace all right
now do you know the stories Brian uh no
I just played the video oh yeah let's
just look at this so they're fishing and
it boats all right out I'm sure they
don't know what Twitter you're not god
[Music]
that's scary jump off oh my god [ __ ] my
god yeah it's not good I didn't now what
if you got low real low oh definitely
got to get off you got to jump off so
what happened let me read it oh holy
[ __ ] that was scary hmm troll hey hey
another boat just wasn't paying
attention he just couldn't see God that
other boat was coming in oh he was just
going fast and couldn't see I'm [ __ ]
you're going no that's a guy not looking
at what boats are so dangerous me out
there yeah they are tell you what else
dangerous you can be driving your boat
and a fish jumps in here and it smacks
you right in your face I'll have them
people die that way well especially it's
the Marlin uh-huh well no I'm talking
about the old perch nah ghosts you know
Marlin take the old nose through the
heart
no me neither but I can imagine no but
in if you you can beYOU can [ __ ]
YouTube
fish smack somebody in the face good no
there's I guarantee you there's a video
of a swordfish stabbing a man mmm they
jump in the end go crazy yeah you die
but I'm saying when you're when you're
in your car
yeah carps that's what they do God see
how these are flying crab yeah got many
Asian carp that's hilarious
see now when you're in a speedboat and
you're doing that and a carp jumps in
the air or getting hit in the face
they're both hate this is whatever
chinko do swordfish stabs a man sir oh
he's harmless
fish three stabs man in the mouth
huh in pills face oh I did see this
awhile ago it's actually after they
caught it all those things go why when
you catch them baby stuff the coast and
they are known for their spectacular
fighting ability yeah they're fighting
to stay alive for guys from in time the
Marlin launches out of the water
it's horrifyingly clothes not really
horrifying it jumps out of these idiots
or catches and then the fish in our area
would Steven and the Marlins deadly bill
is shooting straight at Steven's face
it's what you get a bit Stephen tries to
block the top recreation fish with his
arm but the Marlins spear like Bill
stabs into his mouth oh Thresh's from
side to side
the angry Marlin slices the back of
Stephens throat and tears up the inside
of his cheek thankfully the deadly bill
pops out of Steven's mouth when the
Marlins body crashes on the side of the
boat and flops back into the sea
the fish said enjoy the fish oh my god
how you like me now [ __ ] deep
throat this knows they're hot enjoy the
fish why deep throat you gotta calm down
man there's not a better one huh
fisherman gets stabbed in the face go to
that one in power by oh this one this
one I want to see that Fisher fishermen
get stabbed in the face yeah right there
it's not the same you know
this is what you get dog any [ __ ]
wood swordfish Marlins and stuff man
they're so cool oh he's gonna hit it -
yeah they kill it yeah with a beautiful
animal in it what you get [ __ ] that
swordfish is one [ __ ] high how cool
is that how cool is that thing oh man
did you [ __ ] up god that would hurt
how about the guy deep smelled that
one's nose that's like the bullet that
impaled that guy through the mouth
what's this it's soy sauce Oh Oh God
[ __ ] what makes you feel sad now that is
that the skin because that's kind of
that looks like it's through the bone
bro
best through this that's scary oh my oh
this makes me feel sick can't wash that
makes my nuts tight enough look at him
he's like ah is it real though yeah
that's real okay alright doesn't know
that you like I find myself Duke folding
my arms kind of tight well this one's
not a big deal but do you guys know who
this guy is cuz I don't he got cast as
Drago son who is he Romanian boxer
Florian
Mona to Montana joined Michael B Jordan
Smith Sloane and creak - yeah you know
like sage Northcutt was gonna go for a
drago son steel all just like him nice -
DC lawyer he's too short any so this guy
got him not a big deal it's pretty big
alright okay so you guys are talking
about the only big stuff right yeah so
that girl mckaela Moroni
I guess she signed an NDA with USA
Gymnastics a while ago that says she
couldn't stand trial she couldn't talk
about anything that happened with that
one guy Larry Nassar yeah but ended up
you know these guys not think they're
gonna get caught when they all hate this
way he must not they're sick and they
must not I think these little girls are
never gonna say [ __ ] so the u.s.
gymnastics they actually held on to that
NDA they didn't they didn't let her
speak until chrissy teigen
did an Instagram or a Twitter post
saying that she'll be because Andy is
you you pay $100,000 if you say
something yeah so Chrissy Teigan says
I'll pay that price you just do it Wow
then the next day they said yes you can
speak without being fine oh thank you
USA Gymnastics thank [ __ ] how about
how badass is Chrissy Teigen yeah Wow my
face hunter I'm 5 she speaks I yeah ok
[ __ ] you USA Gymnastics yeah better you
thinking such a pay-for no problem yeah
now you say whatever if somebody Todd
you see what she came out and said no
powerful
in this what what no yeah yeah so what
did she say you'll have to play it I'm
sure they show it but she tears into
this dude yes she does
type move chrissy teigen the hell yeah
they not show it you just never think
that's happening to them let doctors
know this is october doctor molesting
everybody for several years and hundreds
of girls over 140 girls what else you
got you good luck in jail bro oh yeah
well they have to they keep him in a
special Jail let's get you in I think
that was it that's it yeah yeah
she can get a new haircut everybody if
you can't see him MJ's being gone I
think she's taking a [ __ ] hey Jun why
did you decide to shave your head I had
a shave for like a week or two I think
two weeks I don't know just felt like
doing it all right man good I like it
I'm strong hey who sent us that skull do
you see the new skull you don't need a
brain didn't see it be it was it at
Buddha what does it Buddhist some took a
picture of the actual tag so it's pretty
well done handmade it's a human skull
that I think actually think chin made
himself and then said I hate it but
Tyler Tilley no boots their company a
Buddha what Kim a shout-out Buddha let
me get that card
um I should have gone my story here [ __ ]
still want a gold medal after dealing
with all that after done with beam oh
it's at Bangkok skulls Bangkok that
Bangkok skulls
I don't think sick right alright be
alright buddy I'm off to Boston buddy
yeah you are pal Wilbur I will see you
Friday night
there it is you're Boston's you can
Bostonians I need we're selling well in
Columbus Ohio
what is it January 25 26 27 funny bone
Columbus and then we got the Improv in
DC February 1 2 & 3 and I
the comedy drag it out comedy comedy
work work downtown Denver 31st Wednesday
night the February 1st is sold out and
then February two and three I'm in st.
Louis and then end of February February
23rd to the 25th I'm at La Jolla the
economy store basically San Diego
Vancouver March 1st that bad boys almost
sold out in the Brian I have together
March 2nd in Vancouver and then Tampa
and West Palm Beach just announced Kitty
it's now Florida I'm come and squeeze
those goddamn oranges and lock up the
alligators I'm coming see fat cake on
Brian and myself get your ticket son
this is a finer kid we're out